this week we're going to do something
different on this podcast this podcast
is about this podcast so many of you
have asked me questions about this
podcast how it works how big the team is
how we pick and find guests how we make
a successful podcast how you can build a
successful social media channel or
personal brand and also
how much money you can make from a
podcast at the end of the day i just sit
here and talk i get to have interesting
conversations with people i genuinely
find interesting so i think people
typically assume that having a podcast
is just a labor of love now that is true
i don't do this for the money i'm
fortunate enough to have made a lot of
money from the first company that i
founded i do this because i love it of
all the things of all the revenue
streams i have in my life podcasting is
my lowest financial return on the amount
of time it takes me
however this podcast will make millions
this year so this week i'm going to tell
you the truth about everything after all
this podcast was founded on truth and
honesty and i've not seen any other
podcasters tell you the things that i'm
about to tell you about this business
about this medium and about this
industry i'm going to show you exactly
how much money i make from this podcast
how i do it how i did it and how anyone
else can do it too with
six or seven simple pieces of advice i'm
also going to tell you all
the non-financial reasons you should
start podcasting even if it never makes
you a penny and some of these things are
things that i came to learn over time
some of the things i never ever expected
and some of the things some of the
upsides and benefits non-financial of
starting a podcast have quite honestly
changed my life so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
so here's the thing i started doing this
podcast three or four years ago with a
90 pound microphone that i bought in
apple that i plugged into my laptop i
put a duvet over my head 3am in the
morning i went downstairs into the
quietest part of my house
there was no script no plan no team i
edited it myself i um engineered the
audio myself recorded it myself on my
own and i sat there and just spoke into
a microphone about my life and in that
first episode episode one it was a total
one-off experiment in my mind i never
actually thought it would become
multiple episodes or a season and that
renowned line that people in the comment
section often ask about that i just said
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
keep this to yourself was totally random
i didn't plan to say that i said it
because i was about to share my diary
for the first time and i was unsure how
being so vulnerable open and honest
would be received so i jokingly asked
anyone listening to keep it to
themselves and obviously
you guys didn't do that and here we are
three years and 10 months later and the
podcast is done very well it's now the
most listened to business podcast in
europe it's sat at number one in the
charts almost consecutively for 40 weeks
straight and as i said it's become a
multi-million dollar business since
since i founded it
but
and here is my first piece of advice if
you're thinking about getting into the
podcast game
and this piece of advice i guess applies
not just to starting a podcast but also
to all facets of your professional and
probably personal life i published my
first podcast episode three years and 10
months ago but for the first three years
i was never ever consistent with my
podcast when i started one month i might
release an episode and then there might
be a gap of like two months or three
months or a couple of weeks then i'd pop
up with another episode and then there'd
be a huge gap again and so on and so on
and so on and whenever i was consistent
and managed to publish predictably every
monday for several weeks in a row the
podcast audience would grow and grow and
grow and you could see on the graph that
the podcast growth was compounding
if i then took a month off
it was almost like i was back to square
one again you could see on the data when
i had come back from my little hiatus
less people were there to listen so i
realized very quickly that if this
podcast was going to really work and
reach its full potential then i had to
figure out how to be consistent so 10
months ago i made the decision that no
matter what we would publish an episode
on monday every single monday and from
that point onwards the growth absolutely
exploded if you're watching this on
youtube here's the actual graph of
listeners from the minute i started
being consistent with publishing the
podcast every single monday um the
growth exploded by 10x 10 times higher
and as i said this is not a lesson on
podcasting it's a lesson on all facets
of life whether it's building a business
getting millions of followers on
instagram or
even getting into the best shape of your
life figuring out a way to reach that
point of sustainable consistency was the
key to explosive growth and progress
that is a fundamental lesson of my
entire life one that it genuinely took
me 27 years to appreciate
the value of being consistent at almost
anything consistency unlocks everything
it teaches you faster than everybody
else it compounds growth and as it
relates to content and building
audiences it helps to establish a
cadence which keeps them coming back for
more if your podcast is once in a while
or even broken down into seasons that
have these sort of large gaps between
them
i seriously believe you're going to have
a really difficult time growing your
audience especially organically because
people move on and they forget about you
and you fall out of their routine we
publish every monday morning at 7am
because i know 50 roughly 50 of podcast
listeners listen in transit which means
on their way to work on a flight on a
train on a walk or even like on a
running machine at the gym so i want my
audience to know that on monday morning
before you start your week or as you're
getting ready for the week ahead or
during your monday morning commute you
can count on me to be there every week
right here and that predictability for
your audience allows them to fit you
into their habits and we are all
creatures of
habit my second piece of advice is also
a tip about how to grow a podcast and
how i grew this podcast when this
podcast started it was me alone in my
bedroom always in the early hours of the
morning stumbling around with a wire my
laptop in this cheap little microphone
and i loved that i'm so happy that's
where this podcast started it was great
but me talking about myself to my
existing audience was never going to
grow this podcast significantly in an
organic way in order to grow this
podcast i had to find a way to reach new
audiences and to pull them in so i
opened up this podcast to other
entrepreneurs to successful people to
the guests you've seen to come here and
share their diary in the way that i did
when i started this podcast and those
guests bring their audience with them
and the podcast started to grow faster
and faster and faster faster than ever
before it turns out i actually also
enjoyed that a lot more because i got to
meet amazing people learn from them and
be inspired by their stories but it also
saved me tons of time when i did it on
my own i would honestly spend seven or
eight hours planning and writing each
episode i had to do bullet points and
figure out how i'd move from one bullet
point to the next and then if i wasn't
happy i'd re-record the bullet point to
try and nail it it took a lot of time
having a guest means i could just walk
in sit down ask them the things i'm
interested in and have a great
conversation which now takes me just two
hours to record and as i said i find it
significantly more enjoyable because i
get to learn from this incredibly
diverse range of incredible inspiring
people from all walks of life and i
think
generally you guys enjoy that too i know
some of you guys still love the solo
episodes but i think generally it's
really enjoyable to get a really diverse
range of inspiration from unexpected
guests that a lot of the time you've
never heard of before
and i in that format i still get to
weave in my own thoughts and ideas into
every episode although it is centered on
the guest if you want to grow your own
podcast and you don't already have
millions of followers you need to figure
out where this growth is going to come
from where that organic growth is coming
from because spotify and apple podcast
stores and apps don't have any viral
discovery you can't just hit retweet or
share in spotify um and send it to all
your friends like you can on other
social platforms like instagram facebook
and twitter the vast majority i'd say
over 95 of the discovery of podcasts new
podcasts happens outside of the spotify
apple podcast store it happens on social
networks it happens in whatsapp group
chats it happens in
real life by sort of face-to-face word
of mouth recommendations so to grow your
podcast you need to figure out how your
podcast is going to reach a new audience
and do it often and for me this is
achieved in two ways as i said by
bringing guests in but also by having
the youtube channel there's a lot of
content discovery happening on youtube
every time you watch one video it
recommends another and sometimes that
video is going to be the diary of a ceo
so we get a lot of new listeners coming
in through the youtube channel and in
future they might decide to listen on
apple or spotify or to stay on youtube
okay my third piece of advice is
actually a bit controversial
it's really important in all aspects of
your professional life to find the right
balance of having consistency and
quality at the same time and if you know
me you'll know that i'm someone that is
an absolute stickler for quality if
you're one of the many thousands of
people that has worked in one of my
companies or alongside me or with me
over the last 10 years you will know
this to be true my job as a ceo or a
founder or marketeer or a creative is to
set a high standard for the quality of
work we produce as a team and to protect
that standard like a hungry guard dog
and honestly
if you think the standard is too high
for you or you don't like me because i'm
uncompromising about that standard then
that doesn't matter to me because i'm
not here to be liked first and foremost
i'm here to produce high quality work
with a high degree of integrity and work
that we can be proud of everything else
is a secondary bonus everything that is
why we are here that is our central
mission and i never confused that with
that said
on multiple occasions i've invited a
guest to this podcast recorded a full
episode with them and then i've deleted
the episode and never published the
episode because i didn't think it was a
valuable enough conversation to share
with you guys as my audience i genuinely
feel a deep sense of responsibility to
all of the people that listen to this
podcast because i know that you show up
every single monday and often give me
two hours of your time listening to
someone you've probably never heard of
before and you're trusting me to find
interesting people and have a valuable
conversation and to give you
that value on your monday morning so on
several occasions even on one occasion
when the guest was a mega star with tens
of millions of subscribers of their own
which obviously would have done wonders
for this podcast going back to the point
i just made about leveraging people's
audiences
i realized that the conversation was not
valuable enough to share it with all of
you and
that was because for a number of reasons
because it lacked insights because it
lacked inspiration it wasn't an
intelligent conversation it was boring
and it didn't meet my standard so i
deleted the episode told the guest why
and we moved on in fact that even
happened this week i tend to think my
listeners are somewhat like me
um
you must be because i ask questions i'm
interested in to guess and you're
clearly interested in those things too
so if i found the conversation with a
particular guest to lack value or to be
boring then i know you will too and
keeping that trust with you to me is so
unbelievably important
it's not nice for a guest to have their
episode of a podcast deleted and i'm
sure some of them have been a little bit
pissed off historically um because i
might have wasted their time i imagine
if i was in their position and i went on
a podcast i traveled to it and then i
found out that it had been deleted i
would be annoyed too
but as i said all of this stuff to me is
secondary to producing a piece of work
that me and my team can be really really
proud of and if we're not proud of it
then you won't ever see it um and that's
the standard that will always maintain
it's not happened a lot i've got to be
honest maybe three or four times um in
almost 100 episodes but it's an
important point and i think having a
standard drives all of the other work
you do up so even though we've only
deleted four it's definitely meant that
we've set a higher bar for ourselves as
a team because we know that it's
possible that episodes can get deleted
if they're bad
and and so we do a lot more work
beforehand to make sure the guest is
right and the themes and conversation
are going to be right too
my fourth point is probably the point
you guys want to know about the most
which is
money
okay so
as i said i only started doing this
podcast once a week 10 months ago that's
when we made the decision to take it
seriously and to be consistent before
then before 10 months ago the podcast
was basically just a hobby 10 months ago
when i realized i was going to do this
podcast once a week and launch this
youtube channel which meant videoing the
podcast for the first time and really
really really go for it i realized i
would need camera equipment a location
to film it and a team to help me put
this whole thing together i've never
ever cared about making a profit from
this podcast this fits into the things i
do because i love it bucket in my life
and my goal as i said to the team at the
time was just to break even jack
sylvester who i produced this podcast
with made a shopping list of all the
equipment we would need to make a high
quality production and the total for all
that equipment came to roughly 4 000
pounds i saw that list and i said to
jack jack i want you to really go for it
i want to produce one of the best
podcasts in the world come back to me
with another list that is even more
ambitious a few days later jack came
back to me with an equipment list that
cost forty thousand pounds which is
about fifty five thousand dollars he
wanted seven cameras some some of them
are robots that move by themselves up
and down the room some of them are
sliders we've got gopros
state-of-the-art
audio software we've got the best
microphones the best lighting black
uplines you name it it's here and we and
we really obsessed about the small
details of this room the set and how it
would make you feel and how the feel of
the set would impact the content itself
additionally if we're going to publish
four podcasts a month across video and
audio and then promote these podcasts
across social media with video clips but
also find really high level guests we're
going to need a team so here's who i
hired jack who produces the podcast i
also have a full-time podcast booker
called harry who contacts potential
guests i have a full-time pr manager
emma berta who produces the video assets
and clips from this podcast and other
projects callum who produces more video
clips for the podcast grace who handles
the social media across all of my
channels don my manager who works with
sponsors and on brand deals and of
course sophie my long-standing assistant
who helps me organize my diary and
logistics across all areas of my life
so in total i have a team of eight
people that are involved in the
production of this podcast in various
ways it's not cheap especially if you
want to do it properly and you don't
have to do it on this scale podcasting
can be
remarkably cheap especially if you don't
want to video it you can start with what
the 100 microphone like i did as long as
you have a laptop and edit it yourself
and record it yourself you can do it
over zoom but because i wanted to do it
big i knew i needed to find a way to
make money from this podcast people had
historically told me that there is no
money in podcasting they'd shown me the
depressing numbers that you'll see if
you google the term how much money can
you make from a podcast and those
numbers work out the revenue potential
based on how many downloads or listeners
you're getting and then they offer you
some kind of dollar per download and i
read on google when i was starting out
with my podcast that you could make 25
to 50
per 1000 downloads which meant if you
got 100 000 downloads per episode i'd
make 2 500 to 5 000 somewhere in that
range
obviously this wasn't going to cut it
most podcasters make their money from
reading out adverts in the middle of a
podcast episode and most podcasters get
these advert deals from some kind of
podcast advertising company that acts as
a middleman between the podcaster and
the brand
and the brand is basically paying them
on a dollar per download basis the issue
with this right is that the middleman is
taking a big big cut and the brand is
paying a fixed fee per download
regardless of how good your show is who
you are or how valuable your audience is
the brands are basically handing the
middleman a bag of money and saying get
me podcast downloads as cheap as
possible and then they're coming to you
and offering you some reduced rate so
point number five is the approach that i
took i knew the typical way of
monetizing a podcast was never gonna be
enough to cover my costs so i cut out
the middleman here's what i did i made a
list of five companies that i genuinely
use every single day and have done for
years companies that have helped me in
various aspects of my life and all
companies that i really loved in terms
of their mission and values i made a
nice little presentation deck which was
just two and a half slides long showing
my audience the growth and i got hold of
the email address of the ceos of those
five companies i sent them all an email
explaining exactly why they should
sponsor this podcast my ambitious plans
for the future i told them that i was a
customer of their brand proved i was a
customer and i told those companies that
i would make this podcast the number one
business podcast in europe if they
backed me and i would do it within 12
months all five of those companies
replied one of them was the ceo of a
company called huel a guy called julian
hearn and he called me the next day
offering to support me this podcast he
knew i'd been a customer for three years
because i talked about hewlett all the
time anyway he knew every single word i
was going to say about huel would be the
truth and he's never ever ever told me
what to say how to say it what to
promote or anything like that at all he
simply believed in me he backed me he
liked the show and i guess because i'm a
genuine pure customer he knew i would be
a benefit to his brand and no [ __ ] i
am a huge customer i realize creators
and influencers say that a lot because
they have to that's what they're getting
paid to say but no i'm a super customer
i have two fuel fridges in this building
alone that i'm recording this podcast in
now six tubs of it over there on my
fridge um if you opened up the cupboards
you'd find heel products it is the
reason that i'm in the best shape of my
life it saves me huge amounts of time
which is the most scarce and important
thing in my life and it keeps me 10 out
of 10 healthy a few months after healed
back to the podcast i actually asked
julian the ceo if i could invest in the
company too and i ended up being a
pretty significant investor in the
business and i also now sit on the board
too so a really really amazing
relationship
and one that is based in authenticity
and that's all because i cut out the
middleman and i went directly to the
brand that i loved with a really
compelling pitch and a very ambitious
plan for the future
it's not often or typical that a creator
or an influencer goes and pitches
themself to a brand but i swear if you
have the gut skill effort and hard work
to do that you can get amazing deals and
deals that are authentic to you and for
me that was the most important thing
another company that replied to me was
fiverr the same thing they believed in
me i'd actually worked on a project with
them before i used their products i've
used fiverr across a whole host of um
portfolio companies that i'm involved in
i use it for everything from graphic
design to video to audio editing to
translations you name it i contacted the
global marketing director who i'd never
spoken to before found him on linkedin i
told him about this podcast i hopped on
a zoom call with him sent him some stats
around the podcast told him about my
plans and they said they'd sponsor the
podcast too again they've never told me
what to say how to say it they leave me
alone and that makes everything much
more authentic and and much more honest
and i think i think you guys can tell
lastly my third sponsor is my energy my
newest sponsor an absolute phenomenal
british success story co-founded by a
remarkable entrepreneur called jordan
brampton some of you will know i've been
a big advocate for sustainability ever
since i sold my range rover sport and
replaced it with an electric bicycle and
my energy are at the very forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology in
my mind they are the british version of
tesla and so i reached out to jordan
because their values and missions are
completely aligned with mine i asked if
they would support the podcast and they
too after a zoom call and a few chats
said they would love to and my
relationship with my energy has got
closer and closer and closer and i'm now
involved in a lot of other things within
that business too i asked all of my
sponsors for a 12-month contract which
allows me to plan further ahead and to
forecast into higher and i genuinely
have such a amazing relaxed trust-based
relationship with all of them which
means i have that freedom to speak about
my relationship with their brand in my
own way in my own words and that as i
said is incredibly incredibly important
to me it also means that this podcast
has never felt like a job no one hands
me a script and tells me what to say i
do it in my way and that's integral the
psychology proves that's integral to
enjoying something the minute it starts
to feel like a job and you lose that
autonomy
typically that's when motivation
declines and this as i said at the start
of this podcast episode fits into the
bucket of my life that is called things
i do for fun i don't want to compromise
that
if if i ever feel that is compromised
then maybe the podcast would stop
outside of those key sponsors that i've
mentioned i have the odd brand
collaboration or opportunity maybe once
every other month which i might mention
on the show from time to time and my
three key sponsors and my other sponsors
pay varying fees depending on what i do
for them but all in all this year this
podcast will generate over 1.2 million
dollars which is just over 100 000
a month so it turns out the naysayers i
encountered when i started were wrong
and there is money in podcasting and you
can turn it into a really lucrative
business
my last point is a bit of a bonus point
and that's about why i wanted to do the
podcast in the first place and since
launching it the new reasons why i carry
on doing it um i started the podcast
because i believed in the medium of
podcasting to communicate ideas and to
tell stories and to connect with an
audience in a world now where everybody
is so obsessed with reach like 1 million
views 1 million impressions podcasts sat
alone as a different channel because it
offered depth when i started the podcast
i was also making videos on facebook
watch and i remember making four videos
that ranged between 3 million and 33
million views on average those four
videos did 10 million views each
the views were staggering huge view
numbers however the videos were like two
to three minute kind of viral
semi-forgettable highly relatable videos
that after watching most people never
really remembered ever again and one of
the sort of like real world measurements
that i have about how much the content i
make online is connecting with people is
when i meet people in the streets or on
a train or an event what they mention
and people never ever mentioned my
facebook videos and so for me that meant
that those facebook videos weren't
connecting with them at any real depth
when i started the podcast although at
the very very beginning i was getting
thousands of listeners i would get
stopped all the time
even though it was doing a hundred times
less the views as my facebook videos
were when i was getting stopped in the
streets it was getting a hundred times
more mentions and the essays i was i
would get in my dms the the the long
sort of anecdotal explanations about how
it impacted people meant way more to me
than getting a really big reach number
and so i made the decision that i found
the depth much more enjoyable um it was
having a greater impact and when i'm
producing content that i hope will help
people i think of it in terms of the
time it takes me versus the impact it
has and in that department podcasting
sits absolutely alone the audience is
smaller than the viral videos i used to
make but the impact is a hundred times
more profound none of you can remember
the last thing you saw on instagram you
can't remember the last photo you tapped
the last reel you watched but all of you
can remember the last movie you watched
on netflix and i think that's the
perfect example of how reach can be
quite meaningless but depth can be
incredibly impactful it stays with you
and for me podcasting an hour long and
two hours long sometimes at real depth
on very emotional topics has a
tremendous amount of impact which makes
it all for me incredibly worthwhile and
the other really unintended consequence
of doing a podcast was it forced me to
to keep a diary to then sit down at the
end of the week and look at that diary
and to reflect and to take lessons from
my experiences we all go through life
experiencing things those that stop look
at what's happened pick it apart analyze
it and form conclusions on it will learn
more in the same amount of time because
they're taking more from their
experiences my diary keeping a diary
analyzing it and taking lessons from it
genuinely made me smart it genuinely
helped me understand myself it grew my
self-awareness and even if i didn't have
a podcast or an audience i would
recommend that everybody does that
journal have something where at the end
of the week or at the end of the day
whenever you want to do it you reflect
on the experiences you've had and you
extract the maximum amount of learnings
from them i never expected that but
being forced to produce content whether
it's on instagram or a podcast or on
youtube um really accelerates how much
you learn learn about the world learn
about the topics you're discussing but
most importantly learn about yourself
and the other really unintended
consequence of starting a podcast
especially one that's now videoed is
it's helped me sharpen my sword in terms
of my skills in terms of how i speak
communicate my ideas present on camera
and those are skills that are so
incredibly important in the day and age
we live in especially in the social
media era so i would deeply encourage
everybody to find some type of way
especially if you're young and you're
growing up in the social media era or if
you're someone that wants to improve
your confidence or get better at sales i
would find a way to create a pact with
yourself like a promise my promise is i
have to show up on monday and make this
for you create a pact where you have to
consistently produce content as i said
it improves your ideas it improves your
ability to speak and it also helps you
on camera which is an important skill in
an era where everything seems to be
recorded
and the other really unexpected upside
of having a podcast and inviting guests
on was you genuinely make
amazing potentially lifelong friends
there's this ted talk i watched probably
about four or five years ago and it's um
i think it's called like the 35
questions to fall in love with somebody
and it's basically this list of 35
questions that if you ask somebody and
then spend four minutes staring in their
eyes apparently you're supposed to fall
in love with them now of course that's
[ __ ] but there's real psychological
evidence to support why
that would help you connect with
somebody and the truth is as humans when
we open up to somebody else and they
open up to us it's been proven that it's
easier to connect with them so after
sitting here for two hours with a guest
that i've never met before talking about
their childhood and things they've been
through and their mental health problems
and their struggles and their dreams and
their ambitions
after the podcast finishes filming
honestly in like 90 percent of the time
i feel like they're my mate and they
genuinely 90 percent of the time will
say to me let's go for dinner let's go
for a you know and they genuinely mean
it and i genuinely do like you know i
had reggie yates on the podcast never
met him before a couple days later i'm
at his house and i'm having dinner at
his house liam payne never met him
before came on the podcast was at his
house two days ago and we're genuinely
really good friends now and it's the
same with all of my guests i go to their
birthday parties i go to their their
weddings sometimes we become really
really really good friends and it's
because we connected from a place of
vulnerability i never expected that and
for me that is reason enough to launch a
podcast it expanded my professional
network but it also expanded my
friendships and that's really what i
wanted this podcast today to be about i
wanted you to know that you can start
your own podcast and even if you don't
go for the full production studio like i
have you can make enough money to live
off think about it i get paid to sit and
chat with other people that i think are
amazing that is a
unbelievable privilege so what are my
plans for the future of this podcast if
you know me you probably already know
the answer to that question i want to
take it to another level as you may have
seen we launched the diary of a ceo live
which is our live event and we we sold
out manchester's albert hall we had
thousands of people there and it was
i think i'm safe to say totally
unexpected a big production it was
theatrical in its nature there was sort
of like special effects and stuff video
music it was all there and it was a
really really honestly one of the most
powerful evenings of my life over the
last five years maybe the most powerful
thing i've ever done
maybe and we're now going to tour that
across the rest of the uk coming to five
uk cities first and foremost which i'm
going to announce shortly
and in other elements of this podcast
we're going to continue to take it to
another level guests are going to get
even better production's going to get
even better and hopefully i'm going to
get even better too and most importantly
we're going to continue to be consistent
at something that we all very much love
doing
this was a very different episode this
week i hope you enjoyed it i wanted to
finally answer some of these key
questions around this podcast and just
be completely honest with you
and i'll see you again next week we've
got another great guest coming in and i
can't wait
[Music]
you